et la tête classe la tire
mais n'importe quoi et ça rappe ap ap ap
ap ap la pitié c'est pour les faibles
[Musique]
la basse et voilà mais tu veux toujours
à faire petit pour assurer quand une
grosse dondon comme ça on peut pas
rassuré j'ai là ce n'était pas le
handicap sont grosses pour faire du
patinage du haut niveau on ne peut pas
sauter quand on ressent la bonbonne de
gaz et qui font parler comme ça hop
atari va tout prendre pour toi jean mois
le nombre de fois et m'a dit je suis
grosse mais je serais devenue anorexique
quoi pourquoi t'es pas mieux à
l'entraînement parce que jean marc batta
faut que ça vienne de toi ça je ne sais
pas comment contrôler parce qu une meuf
de 15 on ne peut pas contrôler tout ça
toute cette pression et manon qui pète
les plombs et qui veut absolument que
réussie c'est [ __ ] famille au caire
[Musique]
moi j'ai aussi envie d'avoir une vie à
côté il vit avec tes potes avec des mecs
vous ai tant qu'indépendant soirée
[Musique]
rendez vous pour votre image vous avez
dit caractère quand vous battez sur la
glace
m
en cas décision très très vite puisque
le championnat arrive
m
[Musique]